l'utile benissimo vino del 2018
innanzitutto ci tengo presentare la new
entry cioè scimmietta quante carina la
amo tantissimo come sapete salvo di
chiama scimmietta quindi è insomma sono
io
i veri mariners lo sanno che ho un
debole per lo shopping in particolare
quando ci sono i soldi insomma combino
qualche danno ecco questi sono i danni
che ho combinato ultimamente quindi
compriamo gli occhi alla nostra
scimmietta così non rimane traumatizzata
dai danni che ha combinato la sua
padroncina e iniziamo subito il primo
danno che vi voglio far vedere è un
danno che non ho fatto io quindi
partiamo subito super tranquilli perché
i soldi non erano miei
e infatti ve l'ho ringraziato mio padre
e non è questa la sua busta non la trovo
più quella originale il cappotto e dimas
che è un brand che a me piace tantissimo
so se lo conoscete e questo è il
cappotto che mi ha regalato a bit
sempre per i saldi però madrid perché a
votare se così instagram avrà visto che
sono stato a madrid appunto per passare
le feste con papà che viveva e niente da
un sacco volevo rapporto di questo
colore
all'inizio non ero super convinta non vi
dirò che lo stupendo tutti i giorni
infatti è uno di quegli acquisti che
tanti di voi conosceranno calizzano non
mi entusiasmano e che poi tavolo
sfruttate più di quelli che magari
negozio mi entusiasmavano un sacco
chiudiamo la parentesi regalo di papà
perché adesso purtroppo entriamo nei
danni che ho fatto io
quindi come i miei soldi da dove partire
allora questi video preti a madrid da
other stories e
mi cacciano sacre volte mistico a milano
erano tipo scusate al 50 quindi ho detto
ma si è un colore che non metto tutti i
giorni però mi piacevano non ci sarà
occasione vuoi non trovare un'occasione
per mettere i guanti abbinati al
berretto a buy
poi sempre d'aver stories però qua
milano ho preso questo per avete già
visto nelle mie storie perché l'ho visto
tanti di queste cose che vedete gli ogm
se quindi non c'è il cartellino perché
chiaramente ho già utilizzate
e questo tour banchino qui che estra
caldo mi piace un sacco è molto
originale perché non è il solito
berretto che hanno tutti e costava
niente quindi l'ho preso poi ho preso un
sacco di vestitini sono che il col fatto
che alcuni li ho messi altri e ho
lasciato il torino non ne ho trovati in
questo momento che poggerà il video
quindi vi faccio vedere questi due
intanto con gli altri farò vedere nei
prossimi video sicuramente li indosserò
oppure sinistra
il primo è questo che è di forever
twenty one mi piace un sacco perché
nella trentino come piacciono né
perosino come piace a me e alle ma
ritiene come direbbe mia mamma in stile
vittoriano è molto carina e poi c'è
questo qui che uguale a quello che
avevate visto in un libri natale che vi
è piaciuta un sacco era a bordo o questo
qua è uguale nero di velluto e questo è
di forever
ma stiamo adesso all'intimo deve vedere
o la bustina seria che sia di yamamay
che di victoria secret di yamamay ho
preso due completini lo slip in entrambi
i film sono lavare perché ne ho giocati
quindi vi faccio vedere solo reggiseno
comunque sono abbinati è molto molto
carino adoro questi due colori ha donate
anche voi
è questo qua invece nero poi con una
fantasia molto floreale mi sembrava
molto primavera quindi visto sono già in
punto primaverile l'ho preso con i
rispettivi clip allora passiamo subito
questo per un attimo non è secondo
passiamo alle scarpe che non possono
mancare prima poi farò un video facendo
vedere scambi allora tutte e due di
steve madden tra l'altro un'era e saldo
l'altra no chiara nei giocatori negozi e
punto subito e scaroni saldo ma siamo
tutte cosi confermate venuta casa quindi
iniziamo da quelle in sat e da quelli in
saldo è un semplicissimo e sandalo
oddio semplicissimo prof non è proprio
subissimo però mi piace un sacco e
è tipo oro bronzo con tutti gli strass
non rende tantissimo così ma vi assicuro
che avere st de lio la stessa indossarlo
perché la pedicure cha va beh ne
riparliamo poi quando sarà la stagione
giusta ha comunque quest'anno 108 e avrò
le ho pagate le forze 50 quindi direi
top
il secondo paio di scarpe e è molto
molto molto poco sobrio
se potessi riassumere questo paio di
scarpe con una citazione la situazione
sarebbe kira kira può accompagnare solo
chi conosce kira kira avrà già capito di
cosa sto parlando
ecco se la sobrietà avesse dei piedi ai
piedi probabilmente avrebbe love
creiamo lo disse non me ne frega niente
se alessandro meno perché tanto dovevano
essere v e vi dirò il tacco basso per i
miei standard però era troppo bella per
lasciarla lì sulla mensola doveva essere
mia e dovrà stare la mensola della mia
strategia che quindi ero presa
passiamo a lui questo sacchetto ha una
storia un po come la prada quindi ve la
voglio raccontare l'avevo visto questi
questa cosa che non ve la faccio ancora
vedere prima dei saldi e mi facevo un
sacco costano un botto non mi serviva e
quindi ho letto ha detto sarebbe un
capriccio lasciamo litri nel negozio
però cosa è successo che anche stavolta
come con la brava sono stato fortunato
perché sono arrivata il terzo quarto
giorno di saldi è in esposizione c'era
lo stesso modello ma di un altro colore
tipo rosino così i would e quindi ho
detto chiaramente il nero che l'avranno
fatto fuori il primo giorno di saldi
figurati il normale chiedo la commessa
per scrupolo va a vedere il magazzino e
dino portano al nero dicendomi si stata
fortunata perché abbiamo esposto
quell'altro colore senza pensarci nero
abbiamo tenuto dietro e quindi l'ultimo
l'ultima taglia piccola del nero la tua
migliorativo wow
salvo era tipo sono contento per il mio
portafoglio meno ma bando alle ciance ve
lo faccio lo faccio vedere
siete pronti
[Musica]
ecco il cappotto più sobrio che mai
avuto né l'armadio e l'uomo senza tacchi
sembra un po un piccione però con i
tacchi che mi slancio a un po di più ma
la sua degna figura ha chiaramente da
coro nero e niente anche questo diciamo
non era necessario però lo spitzer mi
sono voluta togliere perché fino adesso
ne ho avuto uno che era un po rovinato
gli anni eccetera eccetera è anche il
colore aveva stufato e quindi lo cercavo
così anche qui come per l'operato della
stata fortunata perché entro appunto da
prada e i primi giorni di saldi e
c'erano vari modelli ma colori un po
colori che non mi piacevano oppure
fucsia che come ho detto l'ho vinto per
anni fucsia dopo un po ma anche bene
cambiare e come sapete per me o e oro o
è nero poco a vedere all'esordio non è
niente non c'era quindi me ne torno a
casa con la coda tra le gambe
poi qualche giorno dopo sempre change il
ripasso c'era quel modello che c'era in
tutti i colori stili in nero chiedo la
commissione fa
oggi non ho messo neanche noi lo
sappiamo quelli che mettono cosa lo devo
prendere subito cioè ma questa gioia
così in pista sta bene è in te lo compra
chiaramente ci sembra affatto come
potevano comprare un sembra brutto
pareva brutto e quindi l'ho comprato vi
rendete conto che non l'ho aperto fino
ad oggi per fare il video per farvi
vivere il momento dell'apertura della
scatola insieme a me cioè ragazzi quanto
siete importante per me lavora una 3
milioni
siete pronti per l'immagine degli stack
e cioè normalissimo però io ho
innamorata di questo portafoglio che
considero più il gioiellino di questi
falli e sono molto molto froud di questo
acquisto come chiaramente mi piace un
sacco e oro nero quindi proprio di così
non si poteva
ma soprattutto a livello proprio di
utilità a tutti questi questo posto per
le tessere che io veramente non sapevo
più dove mettere di solito il portafogli
i normali non hanno tanto costo volete
essere ti dovresti prendere comporta
tessera parte dio sicuramente perderei
può che essere che vanno da so qual caso
alla palestra alla postepay
al profumeria ad hoc per ogni cosa anche
per la farmacia e seconda testa quindi
piena di tester e avevo proprio
l'esigenza di avere il posto per mettere
tutte le mie tessere e vederle cioè che
di solito le mettevo nelle cassettine di
dimostrare gli e guardare ancora lì ma
infatti mi è capitato spesso che mi
chiedessero scusa la testa e io per
pigrizia e andare a cercare scovare
dentro dicevano nel secondo
non succederà più non succederà più
perché adesso il portafoglio tattico oro
nero di prato è bello è fantastico
siamo giunti alla fine del video spero
che gli acquisti vi siano piaciuti
fatemi sapere cosa ti è piaciuto di più
a me
chiaramente la cosa mi piace il proprio
di più di per youtube e lui non vedo
l'ora di riempirlo di tessere magari
anche di soldi per adesso niente come al
solito se ti è piaciuto il video
mettevi un bel live che lascia di un
commentino e se non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e diventate dei
veri mariners mando un bacione in
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
facebook in frenata e music a est
[Musica]